I think what people have to adapt to the
fact that systems chronically collapse
at every level of severity.
And that's life life.
He is the sequential collapse of
systems at each level of resolution.
And so systems last for a while,
great depend on,
but then they,
then they collapse.
And you need to be the sort of thing that
can transform itself during a collapse
so that you're there for the next system.
And that's a death and
rebirth essentially.
That's your death and rebirth so
that the old you that was in the old
environment gets punished out of existence
and that hurts like hell and gets you
all depressed and anxious and then
you're in a state of crisis and as things
fall apart and then up comes a new you
and there's a new environment and away
way you go.
And so people have to be,
people have to be disciplined enough to
be part of a system and flexible enough
to transform when the system fails.
And that's basically the two fundamental,
uh,
w adaptive elements that
enable success of living.
And people have known that in one
form or another for in story form for
thousands of years.